a call to Arms to his followers like
other critical moments in his political
career president Gustavo Petro summoned
the streets to back his ambitious
political proposals in this case a
health reform he argues will end Decades
of inequality and exclusion the first of
many
what we have then are three reforms and
not the last and only ones reforms that
seek to guarantee the universal rights
of the people to work health and to
pensions
the actual text of the reform was
presented on Monday after months of
controversy and speculations
Colombia's healthcare system in which
workers pay to be affiliated with
private sectors providers has for years
suffered from corruption and difficult
access to services
yet it has gradually improved over the
years
the government is now proposing a
profound overhaul it would end private
management of funds while promising to
improve Primary Care expand access to
treatment and raise healthcare workers
salaries
people today struggle to get access to
healthcare someone with a serious
illness like cancer can spend months
trying to get an appointment and also a
lot of time trying to get surgery too
many have died before they are ever
attended to
but the reform will face a difficult
process to get to Congress the proposal
has created fractures inside Petrus
Coalition and even in his cabinet
so the president who was elected on the
wave of unprecedented Street protests
backed by unions environmentalists and
students has called on the people for
support Petro's use of mass mobilization
has been criticized by moderate and
centuries politicians claiming that
taking reforms to the streets before
they've been discussing Congress is an
act of populism
I think it's a sign of political
weakness on the part of the government
the government is betting that those who
supported them during the protest will
come out in force in particular the
public workers unions who have the most
to gain from this reform
for now Pedro got his show of popular
support which he will put to the test on
Wednesday when the opposition has called
for a nationwide demonstration against
the reforms